[Music]
thank you
She-Hulk by taking me
thank you your battle with Titania in
court it was incredible
the previously on has become self-aware
and is now doing its own outtakes or the
show's editor is being clever better
than it though just in case I've got
court documents thinking we needed to be
reminded of court documents She-Hulk by
Titania in our universe it takes 12 to
18 months to trademark a name and while
I'm not sure what timelines are in any
part of the story I'm pretty damn sure a
whole year hasn't gone by if you're
going to put Attorney at Law in your
show then you're also going to need to
explain what superpower Titania
possesses that enables her to navigate
the bureaucratic process so quickly
you're listening to Pro Se law 360's
podcast here's a quick word from our
sponsor hey titaniacs did Titania
actually purchase an ad spot on a law
podcast or did the writers of the show
just need Jen to hear another ad from
Titania it's that isn't it you can't
just walk into my house oh just want me
to tell you that kind of just did that
Jennifer's father did the same thing in
the previous episode is she not locking
her doors or are they breaking the doors
every time they come in what the [__] is
going on with this einfeld the indoor
situation side note just in case the
sign failed the indoor situation turns
out to be a Prague rock band I'm talking
about the constant Kramer entry that
appears to be going on here second side
note just in case constant Kramer entry
turns out to be also Chad I'm so sorry
little child but the line starts
there
uh Jamila Jamil is fantastic at playing
snooty characters quickly take a sin off
so I can continue sending the show to
the bad place I can't believe she just
stole my name like that hang on that's
it Jin showed up a Titania's event told
her to stop using her name was told no
and then went and got an orange book of
Frappuccino well the last part is just
what I assume happened off screen it
makes at least as much sense as
expecting titano to be like oh my bad
here take your name back what was the
point of that entire scene She-Hulk is
just a thing that happened to me
inadvertently sharing a perspective with
TV sins writers I need a favor oh well
you know my price
return favor plus interest if there is
interest then regardless of what you
want to call it that is not a price
that's a loan and I'm pretty sure that
makes Nikki a predatory lender also how
does interest even work on a favor if
it's not paid back immediately does Pogo
Nikki five percent of a favor each month
on top of the original favor he borrowed
from her damn it She-Hulk you made me
think about math when I think about math
I get angry and when I get angry I
great now I'm going to be safety orange
for the rest of the episode will you
stand in line with me waiting for a
sneaker drop the Iron Man 3s are coming
down they're limited to one pair per
customer writers thought it'd be fun to
peek the interest of every Sneakerhead
watching then take the plot in a
different direction that never even
gives us a mid-credit scene to provide
some comfort in the knowledge that these
kicks do exist and will eventually be
revealed also no one needs two pairs one
Iron Man 3 was excessive to begin with
I'm not gonna brag to you or anything
but I do have some pretty rare limited
editions that I got from my trip broke
listen I'm not gonna lie I like pug he's
polite charming and doesn't have an
ounce of toxicity in him but I've
already taken off a sin so this sin is
for not letting us see any of Pug's rare
sneaker collection show me the Epic
superhero sneakers Marvel but I am
letting you slide on the interest aren't
I oh no I'm not going down that road
again math is my greatest enemy with the
exception of the entire state of Ohio
here's two sins for almost getting me
riled up about numbers again this is
Avengers you don't like Avengers I got
Avengers this backroom hustle that turns
out to be counterfeit merch is funny but
don't think I can't see what's going on
here Disney Marvel plans to make inroads
into the counterfeit Market by making
their own counterfeits which by the end
of the episode will be a coveted
commodity and as the mouse machine gets
increasingly more market share the
profitability for other counterfeit
manufacturers will plummet meaning that
former counterfeiters will have to make
counterfeits of the counterfeits now
because of the inverse property of
counterfeiting this will result in the
counterfeiters making authorized
merchandise and once the pendulum swings
too far in that direction Disney will
reverse course starting the cycle all
over again the whole time always being
the invisible hand on the Wheel steering
the ship and our lives from port to port
as we suckle on the teeth of our new
entertainment Overlord also thinking
your purple Easter egg would distract us
from the iron person with an arrow
pointing at their genitals as they wait
for the chat with the super exclusive
super tailor I'm left wondering what was
even the point of that bootleg
merchandise gatekeeper sub boss guy that
required an offering to set up this
meeting took them all five minutes and
probably like 20 bucks to get here this
whole Adventure reeks of Kanto bite why
did I pass a billboard on Santa Monica
Boulevard today advertising
a She-Hulk booty boost smoothie I'm just
gonna assume it's because the alternates
of booty burst Booty Juice and booty
sweat tested poorly across nearly every
demographic but it's more likely that
the writers needed colorful line of
dialogue that paired well with your nuts
that you were eating so we would know
that you really are salty [__] as
opposed to a sweet one geocaine H made
Shield the face of our superhuman law
Division and now we find ourselves in
the middle of a frivolous lawsuit
apparently GLK and H also did not do any
Research into making sure that the face
of their superhuman law division owned
the trademark in other words show is
saying that this company of lawyers
didn't do law did Doctor Strange have to
trademark his name did Thor you chose
two examples of people who use their
real names
okay that one got me but the humor in
this isn't gonna stop the sin you're
getting for bringing up a valid question
about Captain America Falcon and the
Winter Soldier but not answering it this
is the person who legally outmaneuvered
to you well she is smart enough to run a
successful business unethical sure but
successful nonetheless so judging her
legal prowess based solely on this giant
hat is a surprisingly shallow
observation for a show centered around
the concept of people growing bigger but
if you're going to be my client you need
to dress like you respect yourself and
not like a football player pleading no
contest to a DUI this case is resolved
so quickly that Jennifer won't even get
her clothes in time enough to be the
well-dressed client Mallory deserves and
Nikki will momentarily reveal that she
is already litigating her besties
fashion crimes so why is line you
obviously spend a lot of time thinking
about what you're going to wear for an
intelligent lawyer who uses smart words
she sure spends a lot of time booking a
judge by its cover
you know what I mean Miss book may enjoy
wasting the Court's time but you can be
certain that I do not wasting the
Court's Time by smugly saying that
someone is wasting the Court's time
cliche is no one in the court concerned
about this throat flashing gesture even
the NFL an organization built around
bodily harm issues suspensions and fines
for this kind of [__] but you can just
do it in court and no one cares
Luke has to act like this is
unfathomable because not believing that
the star of the show could possibly be a
star is some kind of multiversal
constant used to Mark the beginning of
the character's aesthetic transformation
this douche ex machina will turn out to
be the key to Jennifer winning her case
against Titania I made a dating profile
as She-Hulk every single one of those
dates is a corroborating witness this is
how I win this case holy sh are you
gonna tell me that the writers created a
checkup's date Montage in the last
episode that's not only impressive it's
Sensational you have been served my
client wrote and I quote mean green and
straight poured into these jeans we
would normally say roll commercials here
but to stay on theme I'm gonna go with
the prosecution rest uh the prosecution
rests maybe listen I'm really doing the
best I can here would you have gone on
the date If She Hulk had instead
presented as Jennifer Walters look I I
don't mean to be rude but no this is a
great character moment seeing Jen having
to Grapple with the complexity of dual
identities and the pain that comes with
one of them being rejected while the
other one is celebrated She-Hulk kicks
ass but because of all the courtroom
drama that the writers apparently didn't
know how to navigate we find ourselves
much like Jennifer emotionally confused
and hoping for something more this
isn't over hater oh boy can't wait for
the show to explain the California
courts of appeal in fact I'm gonna call
my good buddy John Grisham and see if he
wants to watch the next episode with me
[Music]
hello Sean hey it's dicer from from TV
sins yeah yeah yeah uh oh
oh so the restraining restraining order
wasn't a joke oh oh that's a real that's
a real Court Document oh sorry I thought
I was thought it was a little bit of a
gift yeah I've been watching She-Hulk
again and oh oh okay I'll hang up now
sorry sorry Mr Grisham I don't know any
other lawyer who would humiliate himself
that way to win a case Fletcher Reed has
entered the chat Holloway could never
have gone through that he's
he's mad he's the most likely true based
on everything we know about him but the
show has produced no evidence to
corroborate the statement and he seems
like the type of guy to pledge a
fraternity so objection hearsay motion
dismiss other court words think about
everything that She-Hulk brings to the
table and those guys were my best option
I know I'm about to since Blaine my way
into the middle of this conversation
there's more about commiseration than a
strict interpretation of her statements
however Mallory literally just said the
opposite of this in the previous scene
look Walters but that extremely
attractive man said in there you can do
better so let this thing be a reminder
that constantly reminding yourself of
your value can be an essential part of
self-care oh yeah my clothes oh [__] yo
TV show in your fourth wall breaking
after thought about the new wardrobe
that you're not even going to show us in
this episode
I like it of course you do because I'm a
genius do fashion designers actually
have such massive egos or do we all
think this makes sense just because this
is the most common way they're portrayed
on screen Tinsley does client
confidentiality mean nothing to you oh
great chess with this show needed more
lawyers
sorry little child everyone hates you
we'll Fork you too I need a favor oh
well you know my price
return driver lost interest I'm not
gonna kill my dad why did I pass a
billboard on Santa Monica Boulevard
today advertising a She-Hulk booty boost
smoothie that's not actually me I'm
gonna stop you because you know none of
that's my concern oh oh okay I don't
know how to [__] drive I don't know
what any of this [__] is that I'm
[__] scared first of all sham
wow I I don't actually need a suit like
that I just need a business suit not
capes we had a great date she battled
demons come on I was wondering if you
want to grab a drink with me tonight if
you're not busy if you are it's
completely and totally fine we could do
it another time tomorrow or next week or
never at all ever